[Music]
joining me now is carrie severino a
former justice thomas supreme court
clerk and judicious judicial crisis
network president and mike davis a
former law clerk for associate justice
neil gorsuch and article 3 project
president mike let's start with you um
we all know
what's happening here we know that this
leak was done with a purpose
uh but even threats of justices you know
they're they're they're taking they're
taken seriously but
walk us through
what may be happening in layman terms if
you could
yeah i mean if you're making threats
against supreme court justices you are
violat violating federal law there are
there are laws on the books for assaults
for threats for conspiracy for
obstruction of justice and it is
disgraceful that attorney general
merrick garland a former federal judge
himself deputy attorney general lisa
monaco
fbi director chris wray the u.s
attorneys in d.c maryland the eastern
district of virginia crickets from these
people this is unacceptable these are
these are real threats against the lives
of supreme court justices and they need
to step up right now and do something
about this yeah carrie and we'll get
into the substance of of what's
happening or the lies about the opinion
but that is a question is it not we're
we're at a time where we've had 16
months of democrats screaming incitement
incitement insurrection insurrection
and now
gen saki's kind of like parsing your
words mincing your words about what this
is this intimidation campaign which i'm
calling terroristic because i think it
is against the justices do they have
adequate security dovetailing from what
mike just said
oh i sure hope so i mean i i agree i
think this is one of the most concerning
things about this leak not only does it
strike a blow at the trust inherent in
the in the internal workings of the
court but this is a real act of threat
against the justices themselves i know
that they are ramping up security but
this is why i think a lot of us have
said let's let's just issue this opinion
right quickly i i think it's no surprise
though i mean jen saki remember used to
work for demand justice this is like the
most radical left-wing dark money group
out there these are the people who were
praising the leaker saying we need more
supreme court leaks this is the people
who have a board member who says the
constitution's trash and should be
scrapped they want to have more justices
yesterday they said in the court they're
trying to use this to kind of pack the
court so even if they can't switch this
decision now
or somehow said even let's pack the
court before the end of the term oh my
goodness it is it is no holds barred
it's any means justify the end here and
that's what's uh what's so disturbing
about about this league and the threats
that we're seeing yeah mike i mean these
are people who claim to be threatened by
uh pro-life people praying outside
abortion clinics just silently praying
they think that's a threat okay but now
given what's happening you know it's
it's like oh
well yeah we respect the right to
privacy
here's how the cnn framed the threats
against the supreme court today watch
law enforcement officials are preparing
for potential violence
in the capitol and nationwide capital
police are warning the far right is
calling for violence against a religious
group planning to rally for abortion
rights there's a potential for violence
against abortion clinic providers
abortion clinic staff
mike
this isn't journalism
this is just pro-abortion propaganda
we've had pro-life centers
uh vandalized in just the last 24-48
hours which happens regularly
but now the threat is from right-wing
i mean no one should be threatening
anyone here but
that's the framing of this
yeah i mean it's it's gaslighting it's
laughable they're they're saying that
these pro-life groups are threatening
conservative justices that doesn't make
sense i mean these conservative justices
are getting their threats against their
life online and elsewhere right now and
the justice department needs to needs to
step it up they need to start making
arrests for conspiracy for obstruction
for assault
uh carrie i want to read a
recent passage from a website a lot of
lawyers read it's called scotus blog
and start from the premise that there
were actually at least two leakers and
three leaks the first leak was to the
wall street journal editorial board last
week and substance that was at the court
had voted to overall row but that the
precise outcome remains in doubt because
chief justice john roberts is trying to
persuade either kavanaugh or barrett
to a more moderate position
carrie um
knowing these two justices
a 15 15-week
uh ban versus an all-out overturning of
roe i mean what does that make any sense
to you if that in cases in the event is
happening
uh you know i i think the i i don't know
if there was a leak there but i don't
think you would need a leak to come to
the conclusion that the wall street
journal did because anyone who watched
those arguments could hear the chief
justice was just desperate to find some
way to overturn or to uphold the van but
not overturn roe and we all know that's
not legally possible even both sides of
the argument there said no no i'm sorry
you can't do that like and you're seeing
now he's being uh attacked and and his
address is being given out is one of the
people who would overturn roe even
though it's clear he doesn't seem to be
trying to do that was he trying to lobby
those justices that wouldn't surprise me
that wouldn't surprise me knowing some
of the things the chief has done in the
past does that mean that they were
likely to have switched i mean we heard
their just their arguments in december i
actually was very encouraged by what i
heard from justices kavanaugh and
barrett from those arguments because
they both seem to get it kavanaugh liked
his language where he said the court
should remain
strictly impartial here just
scrupulously neutral and not say we're
gonna be pro-choice we're not gonna be
pro-life we're just gonna say let the
people decide these issues justice
barrett was talking about you know the
the ability for people to give their
child up for adoption how this really
shows how how far we've come in the
country
i don't think they were going to switch
well i would i would hope that all the
justices would come out
and unequivocally condemn these these
terroristic acts on the part of
activists and say this will not stand
and they need to find this leaker or
leakers i should say uh out of the uh
out of the supreme court this this can't
be this difficult difficult if it really
wants to be found out uh carrie and mike
great to see you both thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else